Harrell is in Nevada hi Carol
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you it's an honor to speak with you I'll
try to make this very sweet and short
okay I'm 58 years old no children no
dependents married 25 years three years
ago my husband while I was out of town
decided he will want to be married
anymore and walked out three years ago
three years ago so we're legally
separated right now but I guess he was
feeling pretty guilty because he gave me
the cash cash value of seven hundred
thousand the home which is nine hundred
and fifty thousand dollars is mine no
mortgage on it I have three accounts I
don't even know what pure point is but I
put opened up three accounts in there so
I got two hundred ninety seven in one
which gets 2.8 percent you put three
hundred thousand dollars in something
that you don't know what it is well I
tell me that's not right it's it's a CD
and I owned I did it for a year I should
have done it for three years but I was
so confused after you know he walked out
and I was all alone I just put it in two
CDs and I put it in a savings to a point
when will the divorce be final right now
if we're not looking at it we're doing
these money's not you're right this
money's not yours then no it is mine we
know what is not yours papers the papers
have open signed the papers for you have
been signed for the legal separation I
got the house the deeds mine I got my
money in pure point he kept his 401k and
his stocks and a smaller home why would
you stay Merrill like that excuse me why
would you stay married for the insurance
he I guess he feels guilty because I'm
still on his insurance oh that's
ridiculous
you have two million dollars in assets
you don't need to stay married to a guy
that doesn't might be married to you to
get his insurance
right and he also gives me a stipend of
$1,000 a month he can do that without
you being married
it's called alimony it's in the papers
that I don't receive alimony well you
give me $1,000 a month if he wants to
give you $1,000 a month he can do that
you're not required to be married to do
that this is weird Carol yes but we went
to the lawyers it's all signed it's not
we're not divorced he's been gone three
years it's weird we're not divorced
we're not divorced we're legally
separated for five years three years
yeah yeah later get off the ladder are
you having a future like this in limbo
you're just gonna code you don't be
legally separated till you're 80 and you
die no if one of us decides we want to
get married that's when we do it then oh
you don't forget my own insurance it's
just weird
I think he just feels really guilty but
I don't have a crabber if it is guilty
or not it's just weird it is weird yeah
it is weird you guys later wrap this up
kiddo
okay so what's your what's your question
how can I help
so if I've got 800,000 in liquid cash I
don't know anything about stocks or
anything I don't know where to put this
money should I leave it in these CDs my
lord no you're getting one two percent
and you know you if you get one or two
percent you should have been in mutual
funds getting ten or twelve percent so
you're losing 10% sooner than $80,000 a
year so you need to start learning some
things about mutual funds and I'll help
you do that okay you need to sigh I'm
not the investing business but I have
folks that we recommend they're called
smart investor pros click smart Wester
at Dave Ramsey comm it'll drop down a
list of the smart investor pros in your
area sit down with them one of the ways
you one of the things you have to do in
order to be qualified to be one of the
people we recommend is you have to have
the heart of a teacher not the heart of
a Salesman
meaning they are going to take their
time
help you understand what you are
investing in and you you know you need
to have this money put in either some
real estate that you pay cash for that
creates some income and/or some good
mutual funds so that you can create some
income long term and honey I'm picking
on you earlier but you got to hear me
loud and clear this is not emotionally
good for you and spiritually good for
you to be halfway into a marriage I
don't love divorce but you're already
emotionally and spiritually divorced you
may need to make it legal you need to go
ahead and do it and you don't when
you've got two million dollars in assets
you don't need is that dumb insurance
wrap this up please for the sake of your
mental health